السلام عليكم السلام عليكم
دوله تجتمع لمواجهه بوتين وبعد زياره
الرئيس الروسي لماريبول بريطانيا انه شبيه
بوتين وموسكو تحشد 300 الف جندي روسي
لتنفيذ امر بوتين العسكري وفي الطرف الاخر
وزراء العدل يجتمعون من انحاء العالم لاجل
روسيا والرئيس الصيني يعلنها من موسكو
شركتنا وثيقه
والتعاوننا استراتيجي والطائرات الروسيه
تستبيح اجواء النيت مجددا فكيف سيرد اقوى
حلف عسكري في العالم واعتراف امريكي بقوه
الصين الخارقه وبوتين روسيا تشعر بالغيره
من قفزه الصين الهائله وزعيم كوريا
الشماليه يستعد حرب نوويه في اي وقت وملك
السعوديه يوجه دعوه للرئيس الايراني
واجتماع خماسي في مصر لاجل فلسطين
بوتين يرد على الجنائيه من وسط اوكرانيا
عندما اصدرت المحكمه الجنائيه
مذكره توقيف بحق الرايس الروسي لاديمير
بوتين رغم ان المحكمه تعلم انه مجرد عيار
سيطلق في الهواء دون ان يتسبب باصابات
والعيار لما يصبش يدويش كما يقولها
المصريون فان الغرب استغل الموقف ليثير
الضجه ما هو الرئيس الاوكراني
يؤكد ان مذكره الايقاف هذه هي نقطه تحول
وان بعد هذه اللحظه ستتحمل روسيا
المسؤوليه عن كل ضربه وجهتها لاوكرانيا
فعن اي تحول يتحدث الجواب كان قد جاء من
الرئيس
بعد زيارته الخاطفه لماريبول وردا على
المحكمه الجنائيه ملوحا بيديه حرا طليقا
وكان بوتين يقول
عن اي محكمه تتحدثون هناك لم يكن امام
الغربي الا انكار زياره بوتين للاراضي
الاوكرانيه اساسا بقولهم شوهد خلال رحلته
الليليه الى ماريوبول وهو لا يرتدي حزام
الامان في ظل عدم وجود حراسه مشدده او
اغلاق للشوارع وهو ما يؤكد ان الشخص الذي
ظهر غير حقيقي وشبيه ببوتين حسب وصفي
صحيفه ديلي ميل البريطانيه لينضم مسؤول
السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيفوريل الى صف اصحاب التهديدات قائلا
اذا سافر بوتين الى واحده من اكثر من 130
دوله وقعت هذه المعاهده الدوليه الخاصه
بالمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه فينبغي اعتقاله
على الفور لكن ما هي الدوله التي ستجرؤ
على ذلك يا هذا الرد الروسي جاء سريعا
وذلك باعلان موسكو فتحه تحقيق جنائي بحق
مدعي المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه وثلاثه
قضاه على علاقه باصدار مذكره توقيف بحق
بوتين هنا ما جعل للغربيين وصله في حلوقهم
نعم او يلوح بيده نازلا من سلم الطائرات
ونقصد هنا الرئيس الصيني
والذي وصل الى روسيا للقاء نظيره الروسي
والهدف يضار تضامنه ضد ما يوصف بالهيمنه
الغربيه وكاول زعيم يرد على مذكره اعتقال
بوتين بمصافحته في الكرملين وبخصوص هذه
المذكره اعلنها نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي
صريحه بان قرار المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
اصدار توقيف بحق الرئيس بوتين ستكون له
عواقب وخيمه على القانون الدولي مضيفا ان
المحكمه قررت محاكمه رئيس دوله نوويه ليست
عضوا في المحكمه الجنائيه مثلها مثل
الولايات المتحده كما قال ليجتمع وزراء
عدل من جميع انحاء العالم في لندن لمناقشه
زياده الدعم للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بعد
اصدار مذكره اعتقال بوتين وبالعوده للقاء
الدب الروسي والتنين الصيني قال بوتين ان
علاقه روسيا مع الصين في ذروتها مضيفا ان
موسكو تتعامل باهتمام مع وساطه الصين
لانهاء الازمه الاوكرانيه هناك رد
شيجنبينج ان بكين وموسكو شركاء بالتعاون
الاستراتيجي الشامل ويجب ان تكون العلاقات
وثيقه بين البلدين ليشهد الغرب ضربه اخرى
تجعلهم يقرعون اجراس الخطر محذرين من
كارثه روسيه قادمه وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه
التي نقلت عن مسؤول اوروبي عسكري بارز ان
المرحله الخطيره من الحرب في اوكرانيا
بدات مضيفا ان هناك اكثر من 300 الف مقاتل
روسي مجتمعينا لشن هجوم شامل في اوكرانيا
ليتمدد الخطر الى اجواء حلف النيتو ليصرح
قائد سلاح الجو البريطاني ان مقاتله تابعه
له واخرى من القوات الجويه الالمانيه
اعترضتا للمره الثانيه خلال اسبوع طائره
عسكريه روسيه قباله سواحل استونيا العضو
في حلف النيتو وذلك في اطار عمل الشرطه
الجويه للحلف الطائره الروسيه رافقتها
مقاتلتا من طراز سخوي سبعه وعشرين اضافه
لطائره نقل اخرى وفق تعبير الوكاله
الفرنسيه روسيا تتحرش عسكريا فحذاري من
القادم ومن الحرب الجويه الى معارك
المساعدات الدوليه هنا وزراء دفاع الاتحاد
الاوروبي يجتمعون في بروكسل للبحث الحرب
في اوكرانيا ليعلن مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه
في الاتحاد جوزيفوريل ان الاجتماع جاء
لرصد ملياري يورو لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالذخائر خاصه قبائف المدفعيه بينما اعلنت
الولايات المتحده تخصيص مبلغ 350 مليون
دولار لاوكرانيا كحزمه مساعدات عسكريه
جديده وبالعوده الى تطورات حرب مدينه
بخموت حيث باتت قوات الروسيه على بعد
كيلومتر واحد من مركز المدينه التي لم
تسقط لحد الان بالكامل في يد موسكو مع
تصميم قوتك على استمرار الدفاع عن المدينه
في ظل في الدعم الغربي لهم بالاسلحه فهل
اقترب اعلان السقوط قوه الصين ترهب
الامريكيين انتم تعلمون ونحن نعلم القوه
الحاليه للتنين الصيني لكن اليوم جاء
الدور على الامريكان ليعلنوها صراحه حيث
اكد ممثل القوات المسلحه الامريكيه تفوق
الصين في العديد من المجالات العسكريه
معترفين بان الاسطول الصيني اصبح الاكبر
في العالم وفق قناه
ونقلا عن قائد اسطول المحيط الهادئ
للبحريه الامريكيه نائب الادميرل صامويل
بارو والملازم قائد البحريه الامريكيه
لتوافق التقارير الاوروبيه ما اكده ممثل
القوات المسلحه الامريكيه حيث قالت وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه انالينا ان العالم قد
تغير منذ الحرب البارده واصبحت الصين
واحده
من اقوى القوه الصناعيه ليؤكد بوتين هذه
القوه الصينيه قايلا ان الصين حققت مؤخرا
قفزه كبيره في تنميتها الامر الذي جذب
اهتمام العالم باسره وقرب بوتين ان روسيا
تشعر بالغيره بعض الشيء من الصين لتقطف
بكين ثمره اعترافات العالم بها حيث اتهمت
الخارجيه الصينيه الجانب الامريكي بتزويد
اوكرانيا بالاسلحه وتاجيج الصراع وذلك ردا
على التيامات امريكيه لبكين بارسال اسلحه
لموسكو وكانهم يقولون للامريكان واحده
بواحده والبادئ اظلم
المجنون يحضر النووي
حذرتكم وكان عليكم ان تتوقفوا هكذا اعلنها
الزعيم الكوري كيم جونغ اون لجيرانه
وحلفائهم الامريكيين ليقف كيمو وبجانبه
ابنته نعم اعلن حاله التاهب في بلاده
طالبا الاستعداد لشن هجمات نوويه ضد
امريكا لانهاء الحرب متهما واشنطن وسيول
بتوسيع التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه
واقترابها من حدود بلاده يشرف بنفسه
وبحضور وليه عهده على تدريبات تحاكي هجوما
نوويا من ضمنها اطلاق صاروخ باليستي يحمل
راسا نوويا وهميا كل ذلك بالاضافه الى
قرابه مليون شخص من كوريا الشماليه تطوع
للانضمام للجيش في مواجهه حتميه ضد
الولايات المتحده وليس ذلك فحسب بل انه
وكالتيون هذا الكوريه الجنوبيه اعلنت
اطلاق بيونج صاروخا بالاستيا جديدا كرد
اخر على التدريبات الامريكيه لكوريا
الجنوبيه وماذا بعد ايها المجنون هل اصبحت
نهايه العالم وشيكا الاحداث والتطورات
استقبل رئيس الحكومه العراقيه محمد شياع
السوداني وزير التجاره السعوديه رئيس
المجلس التنسيقي العراقي السعودي ماجد
القصبي في العاصمه بغداد واكد السوداني
الانفتاح على تطوير العلاقه مع السعوديه
العاهل السعودي سلمان بن عبد العزيز يدعو
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي لزياره
المملكه وطهران ترحب اجتماع خماسي في شرم
الشيخ جمع فلسطين والكيان الاسرائيلي
وامريكا ومصر والاردن ليخلص الاجتماع الى
التاكيد على ضروره تحقيق التهدئه على
الارض لكن ال سيقبل الاحتلال بذلك حقا
تستمر المظاهرات للاسبوع الحادي عشر على
التوالي في اسرائيل ضد حكومه نتنياهو هل
تنجح هذه التظاهرات باسقاط الحكومه فاين
تلك الحكومه انا لا اراها بوتين يرد على
مذكره اعتقال جنائيه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه والامريكان يعترفون بالقوه
الحقيقيه لاصحاب العيون الضيقه فبرايكم هل
يتوقف الغرب عن قراراتهم التعسفيه بعد هذا
[موسيقى]